with the popularity of movies like
Disney's Aladdin the Jinn or Genie has
become a Mainstay creature in the west
they can be found in books films video
games and all kinds of media these
beings perhaps most famous from their
frequent appearance in the Arabian
nights or 1001 Nights have a long and
interesting history in the Middle East
one that is intimately connected with
the religion of Islam and the
pre-islamic folklore of the Arabian
peninsula so for our 2020 edition of
shocktober videos let's explore the
Mysterious World of the gin
[Music]
[Music]
known in the west primarily as Genie the
Gin are associated with humanoid but
ghost-like creatures that emerge from
Magic lamps and grant wishes and while
there is some Merit to this view or
portrayal of the Jinn the Gin are
actually quite different in a lot of
ways than what many of us assume the
name Jin comes from Arabic and is
actually in plural form the singular of
which is usually Ginny making it closer
to the genie used in English the meaning
of the word is probably connected to the
root form Jannah which has the primary
meaning of to hide or conceal
makes sense as the Gin now primarily
conceived the last creatures who are
hidden from our regular senses and
occupy a different dimension of the
world they are sort of invisible
creatures the Gin originates in Islamic
and Arabic folklore they are mentioned
in the Quran as one of three kinds of
rational creatures that are created by
God the Angels were created from light
the human being was created from from
clay and the Jinn were created from
smokeless fire but these fiery invisible
beings predate the religion of Islam and
existed as a very prominent and
important part of the lives culture and
religion of the pre-islamic Arabs
Scholars are unsure about the actual
origins of the Jinn and where they come
from some speculate and think that they
may have originally been gods in the
Middle Eastern generally the Middle
Eastern region
polytheistic Gods who were then kind of
dethroned as the theology in the region
became a bit more complex and other gods
took a more exalted positions in the
hierarchy others argue that the Jinn
were originally conceived of as
malicious spirits who wandered the
deserts and old ruins what is clear is
that they have a very long history some
Scholars indeed argue that we find
evidence of gin-like creatures already
in ancient Mesopotamia in Palmyra which
is modern-day Syria these kinds of
creatures were sometimes called jinli I
don't know if I pronouncing that
correctly but this of course leads some
to argue that the origins of the word
may actually be Aramaic and that the
Jinn were creatures who
were prominent in other cultures and
Middle East that it doesn't necessarily
originate in Arabia itself but
nonetheless the Jinn are most associated
most strongly associated with the Arab
people and the Arabian peninsula in
general they are mostly invisible
Spirits similar to human beings in many
ways but with powers beyond anything
that humans are capable of
they are connected to the deserts and
may have represented a fear by the local
population of the dangers of the deserts
the Gin would hide and inhabit dark
places in the desert among old ruins and
cemeteries they can take on different
shapes and forms including as different
animals like snakes and can come into
contact with influence and even possess
human beings
indeed the word for madman or a crazy
person in Arabic is usually majnun which
translates to something like possessed
by ajin to both these settled Arabs and
the Bedouins the January prominent
aspect The prominent part of life and
their culture one that caused people to
be careful when they ventured out into
the desert or to sort of uninhabited
dark places but it would be beneficial
to dispel some common misconceptions at
this point
sometimes people tend to equate gin with
our western or Christian conception of
demons as these evil creatures who are
out to hurt us or to do the bidding of
the devil but this is actually not
necessarily true for Jinn at all at
least not all of them the Gin are
actually more similar to how demons or
diamonds function originally in ancient
Greece before Christianity made them an
exclusively evil creature in other words
the Gin are neither inherently bad or
good they are just like human beings in
fact they live in societies they have
Kings they have friends they get married
and have children they even have
religions and just like human beings the
Jinn can sometimes be friendly and
helpful and other times they can be evil
deceitful and dangerous so the
pre-islamic Arabs had a strong but
varied relationship with the Jinn they
could be feared and seen as dangerous
creatures who inhabited desolate places
but they could also be helpful and even
a source of inspiration as many of you
probably know poetry was an incredibly
developed and cherished tradition to the
ancient Arabs and the Jinn played an
important part here it is said that many
of The pre-islamic Poets were inspired
by Jinn to write their verses almost
like in a possession and here we also
find further connection with the ideas
of demons or diamonds bones in ancient
Greece the diamonds were often seen as
the sources of of inspiration that that
that could you could say be Messengers
in between the Divine world and the
human world and the Jinn kind of
functioned in a similar way in in
ancient Arabia they would function
almost like middlemen between the gods
and human beings being able to convey
messages through possessing the recital
of poetry
this is also likely why some verses of
the Quran claim that Muhammad's enemies
accused him of being affected by Magic
and things like this as gin possession
and divine recitations were a common
place in the culture of the time and
indeed with the coming of Islam through
the prophet Muhammad's recitation of the
Quran and the religions later vast
spread the Jinn became not just a
creature of local folklore but as an
essential part of a world religion the
Quran in fact talks about the Jinn on
multiple occasions and even has a Surah
a chapter named al-jin meaning the Jinn
so the fact that they are talked about
in the Quran seems to many to confirm
their existence and also help to spread
this mythology to to vast areas across
the Middle East and North Africa and
many other places but it also placed
them in a central role in the drama of
the creation of the human being itself
indeed the Quran seems to identify
iblees the Islamic version of Satan as a
Jinn now some verses seem to imply that
he was a fallen angel like in the
Christian narrative well others claim
that he is a Jinn and the later
interpretation has probably the most
prevalent or at least some combination
of the two Iblis was a great Jinn who
led Jinn armies in great battles against
their enemies they fought for God but
when God created Adam the first man and
asked all the angels to bow to him Iblis
refused and this is the central moment
where Iblis is condemned for his
Disobedience and becomes a shaytan or
Satan so according to mainstream Islamic
interpretation Iblis or Satan has a
different function than in Christianity
he is not a kind of deity or powerful
adversary to God but he is the king of
the evil Jinn who leads human beings
astray it was quite easy for the
spreading Muslims to incorporate the
idea of the Gen into different local
beliefs and folklores the Jinn being
invisible ghostly spirit-like creatures
sheriffs of course just by that fact a
lot of similarities with other similar
creatures in different cultures and so
the Jinn were often adapted and
appropriated into these different
cultures now they're said to be
different kinds of gin not not only good
gin and evolution but actually different
categories of gin you could say in
Robert liebling's excellent book on Jin
called the legends of the fire Spirits
he divides the Jinn into five categories
important to remember here is that the
lines between these are not clear at all
they are sometimes interchangeable as
those of us who have read any literature
involving the Gin will surely know but
in a general sense John is the most
general term referring to all kinds of
Jinn at Large
gin is used to refer to specific gin or
specific tribes of families of Jinn and
these can be either evil or good so both
Jin and Jan are very general categories
shaytan however are always evil thus Mor
akin to Demons as they are the children
or Servants of the chief shaytan Iblis
or Satan ifrits are generally more
powerful than shaytan and are sort of
more morally ambivalent but they are
mostly evil we find the Ifrit a lot in
the Arabian Nights they like to hang out
around ruins they're often winged
creature they can cause things like
sandstorms and shape-shift into
different animals
and lastly the marriage are the most
powerful kind of gin and again are
mostly evil this is the kind of gin we
are most familiar with the very large
wish granting kind are often
unmarried category of gin
for context some interpret that in the
famous story of Aladdin there are two
different kinds of Jinn in this story
The Gin of the ring is a type of Ifrit
and the Gin of the lamp was much more
powerful is a kind of married so of
course in the Disney version a lot of
this isn't there but in the original
version Aladdin has both a ring that has
sort of magical powers and and of course
the lamp and so the Gin of the ring is
thought to be an Ifrit and the the Gin
of the lamp is a modded there are also
further types of gin and names including
the rule which is a type of gin that
likes to inhabit cemeteries can
shape-shift and even eat the Flesh of
human beings very nasty kinds of
creatures or nasty kinds of gin they are
often said to appear as beautiful women
to lure men to their deaths and yes in
case you were wondering this is actually
where the English English word ghoul
comes from I actually didn't know this
before I researched this video so this
is very fascinating to me there are also
many other kinds of gin but not all of
which I have time to go through here but
simply put there are many different
kinds of gin and the lines between these
categories can be very blurry there are
many different myths surrounding the Gin
many of which were spread or written
down in a coast quranic context one such
tale tells how the Jinn tribe's original
Homeland was a mountain called cough
standing on the edge of the world as
I've already mentioned gin are often
connected to certain places they are
said to guard Treasures or haunt all the
ruins many places around the Middle East
that are thought to be infested with gin
even today in modern-day Saudi Arabia
there is a place called Mada in Saleh
which are these old ruins from the
nabataean kingdom
this place has long been thought to be
inhabited by the Gin there are even
stories about how the prophet Muhammad
himself used to Veil himself and walk
quickly as they passed location telling
his companions to avoid it at all costs
because it was haunted obviously there
is also the famous story of the city of
ubar also known as Iran of the pillars
or Atlantis of the Sands so-called by
T.E Lawrence this is thought to have
been this great beautiful wealthy City
in ancient Arabia that was buried in the
sand hence the name Atlantis of the
sands made famous by Lawrence of Arabia
or T.E Lawrence who wanted to search for
it as well as the 2011 video game
Uncharted 3. the ruins and great
Treasures of ubar are said to be guarded
by the Jinn they're also very famous
individual gin many of these probably
appear as the mythology of the Gin
spread to new places and local deities
or Spirits were incorporated into the
mythology of the gin
one such famous example is a journey
called Aisha kandicha from Morocco she
has the appearance of a beautiful woman
with black hair the only difference
being that she has the feet of a camel
like the rule Jen she lures unsuspecting
men into the desert to kill them
many such stories of individual gin
exist they can also as we have discussed
possessed people and there are various
ways to exercise a journey
the sufis and holy men and Mystics often
have a role to play in this to remain in
North Africa and Morocco for example one
way to exercise a gin was to use
ecstatic narwhal music so in our music
is a kind of North African Sufi music so
this was used often in exorcisms to to
to get rid of evil Jinn
incredibly interesting if we then turn
to what is probably the most famous
example of Jin stories which is of
course the Arabian nights or more
accurately the Thousand and One knights
in Arabic called alph Layla walela here
we find a whole host of different tales
that includes the Jinn and some of these
Gins like the story of the fishermen and
the Gin are clearly evil and dangerous
While others can be helpful and friendly
in fact a lot of our conceptions and
ideas about the Jinn
maybe most of it comes from the Arabian
nights or a Thousand and One Nights this
is a very important collection of
stories for our understanding of Arabian
or middle eastern folklore as the Jinn
are thought to live in societies just
like human beings the Jinn as I said
also have religions there are stories
about how some Jinn would listen to The
Prophet Muhammad as he preached and who
later converted to Islam so there are
Muslim Jinn they're also Christian Jinn
there are Jewish Jinn and so on and the
Jinn are subject to God's punishment at
Judgment Day just like human beings are
even today the Jinn are an important
part of the culture of the Middle East
we still sometimes hear stories about
places that are infested with Jinn
people who have been possessed there was
even that Netflix show called Jinn which
obviously wasn't very good at all but
still there are also many today who are
skeptical about their existence as such
many Islamic scholars for example into
favor a metaphorical interpretation or
reading of those quranic verses that
talk about Jinn While others very much
still believe in them as actual
creatures and this is actually an
important part of our discussion well
the Jinn feature prominently in Arabic
and Islamic history in different
writings and in general just in the
Islamic religion there has been a
variety about how people have understood
and interpreted these creatures while
many have traditionally and today seeing
the Gin as real actual beings who
inhabit the world alongside human beings
others have read things quite
differently
there seems to have been some who use
gin to refer to any phenomena or force
that was not detectable by the senses
and many of the more esoterically
oriented schools of theology or
philosophy found interesting ways of
doing or esoteric interpretation on
those quranic verses for example the
13th century Persian philosopher
zakariah kazwini wrote that quote some
consider the Jinn as unruly men but
these persons are of them from this it
seems that some thinkers in this case
from the rationalistic matazida School
of Theology interpret the Jinn
metaphorically to mean a kind of human
being I'm not going to make things more
complicated by discussing theology or
complicated philosophies but this I just
want to point out that the Jinn have
been interpreted differently
historically and today the situation is
quite the same well I would go as far as
to say that probably the majority of
people in the Middle East still very
much believe in the Jinn as actual
creatures there has been as a result of
different factors like western style
education an increasing tendency to be
skeptical towards such ideas and seeing
it as
a Superstition and whatnot so it's
important to keep that in mind of course
to sum up the Jinn are for the most part
invisible Spirits created from fire that
are similar to human beings but also
have very exceptional Powers they are
intimately connected with the desert and
the nomadic culture of the ancient Arabs
and they come in a wide variety some can
help you others will lure you to your
death but all of them tickle our
imagination and serves as a fascinating
part of the culture of The Wider Middle
East
happy October and happy Halloween
and I'll see you next time